hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen ja heute zu einem neuen video
auf meinem kanal meine damen und herren
ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet ich habe mir amazon
kreaturen bestellt für insgesamt 100
euro das hört sich nicht viel an ist
aber für retouren sprach habe ich ja das
ist echt eine menge und das paket das
ankam
das ist okay und das sind meine süße
würde falls ihr euch jetzt erstmal frage
sollte haye luca was heißt überhaupt
dass die amazon retouren bestellt es
gibt eine website einer unserer website
von amazon auf der man sich dinge
bestellen kann wie schon mal sich
bestellt wurden von anderen amazon usern
die fanden die sache nicht gut oder
konnten die nicht gebrauchen wie
zurückgeschickt und jetzt ist die
verpackung beschädigt oder der artikel
funktioniert nicht mehr ganz und amazon
verkauft die von halben preis und dahin
gehen habe ich mir gedacht ich nehme mir
das heutige video einem budget von 100
euro und einfach mal was ich mir für 100
euro alles bei dieser website kaufen
kann dass sie jetzt übrigens in
täglicher pickel also achtet einfach
nicht auf denen ich würde sagen direkt
an mit dem ersten produkt und zwar
gerade das war das erste was wir hier
haben ist das hier jetzt hinter der
kamera so shotgun weil sie das haben wir
erfahren dass hier sind so racer
reflektierende bei castilla oder auf
englisch reflex behalten wolle hier habe
ich mir bestellt ich weiß ich sagt nicht
mehr wie teuer die waren aber wenn ihr
am ende des videos sieht wie viel ich
mir bestellt habe
dann checkt dass die einzelnen sachen
echt hart günstig waren ich habe die
ganze sache wirklich vor einer halb zwei
monaten bestellt ich habe kurz nach
weihnachten die idee dieses video
aufzunehmen und die haben so lange
gebraucht
wahrscheinlich weil die sachen überall
verteilt sind und die wollen ja auch
nicht ganz viele einzelne pakete
schicken aber das ist auf jeden fall das
erste was wir bestellt haben müssen bei
grace reflektierendes sicherte sache
passender kurz aus ich bin harry potter
er kann es mich mal an leuchten mit
einer taschenlampe
irgendwie ist nicht so reflektieren oder
[Musik]
also sieht auch ein foto da wird man
also das war das erste produkt was hier
in dieser amazon retouren box drin war
das zweite produkt ist ein etwas
längerer gegenstand schieße ich keine
ahnung was wir dargestellt habe so ein
regen stehen wollte ich gesagt schon
immer haben und zwar wenn es richtig
krank regnet und man einfach mit dem
desktop mit richtig kraft ring kannst du
so daher auf und hatte durch gucken
das ist nicht blöd und stinkt wollen
dass das bist du das war auf jeden fall
das zweite produkt das sich in dieser
box gefunden hat
das dritte produkt ist das hier ein
seniorenhandy die gesagt bin ich einfach
so vorgegangen dass ich mir hundert euro
so viel wie möglich gestellt habe glas
gab noch günstigere sache hab ich wollte
es auch nicht 400.000 genauso aussieht
das handy von meinem opa schon krass
wenn man eigentlich überlegt dass das
früher telefone alle so aussah dass sie
an der seite ist einfach so ein schalter
wenn man den bug schiebt ist einfach
eine taschenlampe hier vorne ist
eigentlich gar nicht so blöd wenn das
senioren irgendwie im schlafzimmer
liegen haben oder so wir lassen das
handy erst mal noch ein bisschen laden
und schauen ob das am ende des videos
format das ding dann voll ist
wir machen weiter direkt mit dem
nächsten produkt das springt uns hier
schon so hingegen und zwar ein headset
[Musik]
citys katie so letting extra das headset
mit mikrofon ja da merkt man dass es
eine retoure ist es ist sie vorne mega
dreckig oben geht schon wieder kleber ab
von jeder seite sie einfach nur gar
nicht aus wie hinten sind sachen
abgerissen also das kriegt man wenn man
bei amazon retouren bestellt ist aber
nicht schlimm denn es geht ja uns heute
nicht um sondern um die inneren werte
das ist von philipp ist das ist eine
richtig gute marke so sieht das seit ich
auf jeden fall ausgepackt aus ms sieht
echt cool aus eigentlich das muss man
wirklich sagen es hat ein kleines
simples design von hier sieht's bisschen
aus wie so schokolade man sich das auf 6
es ist ja es passt mir überhaupt nicht
ich habe auch im krassen dickschädel ach
so man kann sogar für die rund um
geräusche echt krank hat mir noch
verstehen julia wieviel fingerzeige ich
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt und zwar hier vorne etwas was in
der ecke liegt
es ist das hier schon 1 1 stehen
ich hasse mittelalter
ein ganzes
der in sich hat das nicht gestört aber
er wird ja auch nicht die ganze zeit von
da ist eigentlich ein problem während
julia hier die stärken habe versucht
aufzubauen machen kinder halten mit den
nächsten produkt das hier mit drin ist
er mich ich weiß genau warum ich mir das
gestellt hat das ist ein radio und da
steht einfach werde also ich weiß
eigentlich ist der beschluss für mich
ist es dass der radio das hatte ich mir
auch bestellt ich weiß nicht wer doch
radio hört von euch ich glaube
tatsächlich gar keiner ich weiß noch
früh aber internetradio so das
nonplusultra
es gab so also was heißt früher da war
ich noch grundschule ich habe früher im
radio auf jeden fall immer bundesliga
gehört deswegen bin ich auf jeden fall
noch mit solchen sachen vertraut dann
musste man ihm die ausrichten dass man
halt irgendwie das ohne raschen
radioempfang hatte gesagt jetzt ich
brauche jetzt die steckdose dafür das
heißt ich muss unseren rausstrecken mal
schauen ob das tier dann zumindest
angeht
ich drücke jetzt mal alle knöpfe und
auch an der seite im taschen riskiert
das geht nicht
wo bist du
es funktioniert ist das gemacht also wir
können jetzt einfach mal auf menü
klicken und dann können wir auf
nachrichten gehen und dann sehen wir
empfangen keine nachrichten aber auf
jeden fall funktioniert das ding ich
habe auch ich muss ein sim karte
einlegen mensch ja eine sim karte habe
jetzt nicht auch noch gekauft allerdings
hat juliane zwischenzeit schon unsere
stärke fertig gemacht und weiß ich die
so aus dass uns das in die wohnung
stellen
lampard auf jeden fall ihren platz
gefunden in der wohnung das heißt weiter
geht's mit dem radio wie
[Applaus]
juli
quality sehr gut klappt super
früher da wollen aliens mit uns
kommunizieren
ja ich würde sagen der stelle mache ich
das ding da noch mal ausmachen
allerdings weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt das nicht der kiste befindet und
zwar ist es noch komplett eingepackt
mehr ist nicht
ja das ist einfach ein arm doch nicht
ich dachte mir einfach ein leerer karton
aber was ist global und der baroness an
den stil sogar noch den nagel hatte ich
ganz offen dass ich das hier ist mein
goldener play button den habe ich für
eine million abonnenten bekommen das
hier ist meine silberne play button habe
ich für 100000 abonnenten bekommen das
hier ist mein peperoni und knoblauch
ding das da einfach weil ich das so
gerne essen allerdings sind wir noch
lange nicht am ende angekommen in
unseren ganzen sachen die sich hier in
dieser woche prüfen und zwar mir noch
das hier das ist eine idee leselupe
warum habe ich mit das sonst erstellt
kann ich somit neben einfach irgendwohin
also so groß ist der text jetzt wenn ich
normal leben würde und so groß ja mit
der lese club also so viel größer ist
jetzt nicht geworden aber es sieht gut
aus also das teil ist mehr oder weniger
nutzlos und sieht beschissen aus
eigentlich wie ich war nämlich den
nächsten produkt das sich darin befindet
was glaube ich auch schon das letzte
produkt ist und zwar ist es hier drinnen
es ist meine damen und herren
ihr wüsstet judes blick sie bei jedem
produkt ich weiß nicht was das ist dass
er ist jetzt kommt dann gleich ein
monster ausstellung vor
ja hier ist er nichts drin
es ist eine schatztruhe oh mein gott ist
da viel staub drin also eine schatztruhe
habe ich mir anscheinend pollock
bestellt worden
und sonst haben wir die paketiert
münchen nur noch von ganz viel ruhe und
soll jetzt die richtung 300 euro und 95
cent hat alles zusammen gekostet hätte
dir damit gerechnet dass man für 100
euro bei diesem amazon retouren shop
wirklich diese ganzen sachen bekommt
also um das mal ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen mega high fashion harry
potter sticker eine schatztruhe ein
radio ein handy kopfhörer eine
unfassbare fashion lampe das war
vielleicht war es echt gute
geldverschwendung allerdings hoffe ich
dass euch das heutige video hier
gefallen auch wenn ich euch unterhalten
konnte das gerne einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video hier da schreibt mir gerne
und in die kommentare was ich mir
eventuell ja sonst hätte 400 euro alles
gutes kaufen können was mich in meinem
leben weiter gebracht hätten um 12 uhr
kommen übrigens ein video auf einem
kanal in dem ich doppel interview
also stellt euch allen wecker auf morgen
12 uhr am samstag und dann sehen wir uns
dort wieder
[Musik]